all right much less important news uh on
a lighter note going back to the Super
Bowl before we get to the comment
section and you know people have been
talking about the commercials
talking about it and again it's one of
the things people talk about for like
half a day or less but there was finally
a trailer for The Fifth Indiana Jones
movie and people are because Disney's
doing a fifth one people are somehow
excited about this film let's watch the
trailer
you have we met my memory's a little
fuzzy
are you still a Nazi
[Music]
from hell
they're doing here
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I don't I don't know how people
they people just never learn you know I
I it's this is part of the programming I
guess
and that we are a culture obsessed with
entertainment and um
and when it comes to part of the reason
why we like to be entertained all the
time is because people in fact people
say this I could turn my brain off I
just want to watch something where I can
turn my brain off
yeah well do you ever turn it back on is
is the question
so somehow people never learn because
I'm watching some of the reaction to
that trailer and most people including
like people that I know are
conservatives seem pretty hyped about it
they're pretty excited oh it looks Rose
good this is gonna be great
and I'm just wondering in no offense but
how stupid do you have to be at this
point to actually be excited for a
franchise Reboot film from Disney
like how many times do you need to see
how this works before you learn that it
is always going to be terrible
like it it and the only way to stop it
is if people just stop showing interest
in the films and stop going to watch
them
because what's going to happen is this
is this stupid movie is going to come
out and people are going to flock to the
theater it's going to make a billion
dollars and 90 of those people are going
to leave the theater saying that was
terrible as woke garbage
it was woke garbage that I just gave my
money to and the next time they put out
more well garbage you know another
franchise but I'll go watch that one too
and I'll keep watching them and keep
giving them my money until they they've
until it changes
I will I will reward this with my money
and I will keep rewarding it until
magically they stop doing it
I don't know about that plan
look Harrison Ford is a million years
old
um and then they've got this actress
Phoebe Waller Bridge who is a Bridger or
whatever her name is
who's going to be uh she's in the film
and they're setting her up as the new
Indiana Jones
because remember in Indiana Jones four
they had Shia LaBeouf and now we're
pretending he he was wasn't he uh
Indiana Jones's son in that film and but
now we're pretending he doesn't exist so
I was getting rid of him
uh and they're largely doing that
because well they don't want the new
Indiana Jones who they set up to be a
man at least of all a white man so now
the new one has to be a woman so they're
going to set up the the new female
Indiana Jones
she'll be taking the reins or the whip
in this case so it's going to be a
geriatric Indiana Jones teaming up with
a girl Indiana Jones
and what is the appeal of that exactly
and I can guarantee you that the entire
film it's going to be nothing but a
whole bunch of jokes about how Indiana
Jones is this bumbling idiot man who
can't do anything right and so he needs
the uh the the the smart alec woman
there who can kick ass and get things
done
you know just like your guarantee it's
gonna be the scene where Indiana Jones
is about to be taken out by the bad guy
and then he hears the The Gunshot and he
he thinks that he got shot he looks over
and it's the girl standing there save
the day and she'll make some you know
wise crack you know that's gonna be the
whole movie
and people will still go it'll still
make a billion dollars and people will
still watch it even though we all know
what it's going to be
just let these things die okay let them
die
that'll do it for this portion shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there and uh if you want to
become a member you can do that using
Code Walsh at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]